so he has just an abstract linear
boom it's like he's doing contestants
but i'm not gonna stand here i'm gonna
move off i'm gonna engage him and move
on
outside outside
and learn this pass down
but stay inside and up
outside down but come back
inside and up i'm not staying on the
inside
and going like this i'm not staying on
the inside
and staying up i'm going to transition
between
all of them boom down but inside and up
oh no has to come back
up boom
then get the other arm in learn to
have it in and start
at this angle going this way this is
your zone
sanctuary and you have to worry about
the cross lateral shoulder
this is going to check his legs enough
for you to move
boom if i catch his arm that's where i
stick
if i catch his his arm goes dead i'll
stick at the shoulder
if i catch his elbow that's where i stay
but you don't have your arm here
it's immediately in
[Music]
don't grab though okay so some uh
just some marshall points
so when i step here to the right
the angle of deflection has to go to my
left
so he comes in second point
when i'm on the outside of the arm i got
to be
in the elbow area i don't want to be
down at the hand that's
your aikido wet drink so you take his
hand
and then he follows
you have to guard against him overriding
my
angle of deflection so i push the wrist
he'll use his elbow to go around it
so when you're on the outside you have
to be
in this elbow area so when he goes to do
any of his stuff you still have control
of that joint
so when you're out here the my is gonna
be off it's what you're experiencing but
you think it's fine because you're
in dreamland so when we're here like
this
i'm engaging that elbow
and that elbow is going in
just like the keyhole
or the drill of thai ankle that elbow
goes in
[Music]
so the first move the elbow goes in
that gets his center of gravity starting
to move
and the fight starts to rotate we're now
rotating
that brings it into the kazushi pattern
that i want
[Music]
the only thing is i have to be able to
do this
skill
so boom then guide
it around as he comes around
so you're going to need the ikea
adhesion here so you stick
and you're going to need to cook your
projection into his center
you can't just turn his arms and then he
goes
he goes flying
it is very much
like this rope i wanted to do this throw
i'm in here
everyone would see the mechanics oh yeah
but instead of working on the torso i'm
working at arm length
so boom
okay so in firearms training
you have to have a lot of range rules
especially in beginner classes you don't
know the skill level of
the people on the firing line and what
ends up happening
is a kind of square mentality
a two-dimensional square mentality comes
into the
shooter they're totally unaware of it
whereas in real life i have to have a
360 degree
environmental awareness i can't have a
square
and it can't be two-dimensional
same thing happens in aikido everybody
trains
the mats are generally some sort of
square or rectangle we all take our room
we take a lane even though no one
painted a lane
there's a lane and now you start to
think
in what i call that 12 to 6 line
and now you're not doing the kazushi
pattern you're doing
just an acceleration throw so
we have our lane he comes in and then
i'm supposed to throw him that way
and if he's athletic he'll just run
through through
this not the kazushi pattern
the kazushi pattern is a circle
it starts in a kind of abstract
conflictional geometry he's there i'm
here
but immediately i am
rotating this so
not here and let him and then question
no
this thing happens in very tight
so
so even if i have this circular geometry
and the big kazushi pattern i don't want
uh him to have that capacity to bring
his base of support
back under his lining gravity which he
can do
even with that geometry so it is a yid
yong world
it is a yin yang art he goes
this hand yes this hand yields
and sticks takes over the ik adhesion
but this hand must have a young pokey
projection
so i'm going to take away the ikea
adhesion this hand does not go that way
this hand goes that way
[Music]
not over here this is just an
acceleration through
his head is going that way and then the
coq projection
is
he hits the ground vector
[Music]
i like this
let's